Let's think about how to divide numbers into categories.
This will be very helpful,
because when we introduce the numbers plus numbers in each other,
we will be able to make more concessions more easily.
Let's look at the problem.
Leah is not sure how to add numbers 39 and 61.
Help Lea choose the right option,
which is the same as 39 plus 61.
So, let's look at the options.
In the first version we have 30 plus 60
plus 90, plus ten.
And at first I advise you to stop the video
and try to solve the problem yourself.
So this is the first option,
where did they get these 30?
Well, 30 are the same three,
and I have more than three dozen here.
39 of them are 3
is a category of tens and it means 30 or 3 dozens.
And then we have 60,
And where did it come from?
Very good, in 61,
these six are in the tenths category,
then it is 60.
And then we have 90 plus.
Now, where did those 90 come from?
I do not see any visible 90.
Maybe you get embarrassed,
because there is a number 9,
but it is a unit of units,
not tens.
So it's 9, not 90.
And I also have 1 point.
I do not have any 90.
Also, I do not definitely have 10.
So this version would be right,
if instead of 90?
9 had been written,
and instead of ten,
had been given 1,
because we have 1 class in this category
it would be right,
but this version is incorrect.
It does not say 30 plus 60 plus 9 plus 1
says 30 plus 60 plus 90 plus 10.
So, we do not choose this first option.
Go to the next version, where:
we have 30 plus 60 plus 9 plus 1,
which is correct and correct,
because we have
30 plus 9 here,
which is equal to 39.
And then 60 plus 1,
which turns 61.
So these two expressions are equal.
And why did I want to divide the numbers into parts,
because in this way you can easily say in your mind,
30 plus 60
it is 3 dozens plus 6 dozens, which is equal to 9 dozen.
So, these two parts
are equal to 90's.
And 9 plus 1
turns ten.
And at the end, 90 plus 10,
very well, this is equal to 100.
But they did not demand that we score the result,
but just asking them:
Which of the options is the right one and exactly the same?
The phrase shows what we are given.
And we can say this option:
So we got the answer,
but also make sure that this is the wrong option.
We have 9 plus 1,
after 3 plus 6.
See our 3,
is not just 3,
but it is 3, ie 30 is equal.
Had this been 30?
And this is 6 dozens,
not 6,
then it should have been written in 60,
So this option is definitely excluded.
Take another example.
Which option is the same as in 41 plus 57?
And here, all the numbers are divided into categories,
tenths and units.
So: I have four categories.
So it will be fourteen,
and we have a 1.
Suppose we have one unit.
This is 41.
And then the number 57,
in the category of tens
we have 5,
that is, five dozen
and we have 7 points in the rankings.
Come to think of the options that are the same
What exactly have I just written?
In the first version,
We have 4 dozen
and one point.
It's
It's the 41st.
And we also have,
5 dozens and 7 points.
Thus, this first version fully meets the requirement,
only a little moved.
If we write
4 dozens plus 5 dozen
plus 1 point, plus 7 points
it is the same thing as the first.
And now we already know that we have found the right answer,
but let's make sure that the other
versions have errors.
We know that fourteen are true,
but then plus a dozen.
Here, 1 of the points has been moved
and has become dozens,
then this option is definitely wrong.
And also written 5 points,
but we have 5 dozens,
not 5 points.
So this is definitely a wrong option.
In the 3rd variant, 4 points are written,
this is our 4th,
it is a category of tens,
It is the same 4 tick.
And then it is written 5 points,
This should have been 5 dozens.
It's a mistake, this should have been dozens,
and this is also a dozen.
So, we were convinced that only the first version was right.